how's it going that last talk was really
freakin great like I wondered to myself
I'm like I maintain this web compiler
and like how many like tiny character
tricks can we take from this
but anyways maybe that's for a minute
fire so yes thank you so the title of
this talk is web pack for the state of
the art and so for those who don't know
me I am Sean Larkin and so I'm a project
manager or program manager at Microsoft
working at Microsoft edge and edge dev
tools but you may know me as being one
of the maintainer x' of the web pack
core team and also spent time working on
the angular CLI and just a general
evangelist for open-source
sustainability and then now kind of with
my involvement through Microsoft and web
pack helping represent you all at the
node.js foundation for modules and also
web assembly in their community group so
a little bit about myself is I'm a tech
support technical support rep gone rogue
I got tired of not being able to solve
people's problems and so I started
learning AppleScript like who wrote
AppleScript like yeah like that was my
first programming language and then Ruby
and then objective-c and then finally I
found JavaScript you know I also like
woodworking and Internet of Things but
like I said sustainable open-source
practices is one of probably my latest
passions that I've been following now
you can find me anywhere like anywhere
most in most places with at the lark in
and so if you wanted to tweet this out
right now I'll give you a second take
your time
there's no rush but you can find me on
any of those places
so back back to the talk okay so web
pack for the state of the art and state
of the art so like I just wanted to pull
up a little definition and there is that
how you'd say it I stand off the list
and is that the Icelandic version of
that I'm not sure but you know we're
talking
about the recent stage of development or
I don't want to call what we do
avant-garde but at least you know the
the latest release and what we're
talking about today and so you know like
it was mentioned we did just release
webpack a hundred and twenty hours ago
and it's here it's in latest web pack
for is out and you can get it today but
I want to talk about what web pack four
represents and so for the first time we
decided to take and give our major
releases a codename and so this is
called web pack legato so you might be
like what like I know who's a like I'm a
music major so in college so anybody
else did music okay so you understand
what legato means it's to express notes
in a flowing matter without gaps in
between them but we got this term from
our major sponsor trivago so we we want
to give the opportunity for one of our
largest sponsors to name the to name
this major release and so this was kind
of their explanation you know at trivago
we usually give our projects a name and
a musical theme so for example they're
all JavaScript framework was called
harmony our new framework is called
melody and on the PHP side they're using
Symphony and the top layer is called
Orchestra and so legato meaning to play
without gaps expressive through through
each note to them really embodied what
it meant to have webpack for you know in
their build system and how it ties
everything together and you know before
I go on and explain more I want you to
just look at one of these slides or to
each of them and if you see your company
there or yourself I just want you to
stand up right now so if any of this is
you stand up I know I know there are
many please so I want you to look around
and I want to give I want you all to
give them a round of applause because
this is
because without these people we would
not be here today
and webpack four may not exist so I just
wanted to take take a second and
recognize those people mm-hmm so you
know we wanted to kind of create this
higher level story about what webpack
four meant meant for our users meant for
us and so you know the first thing with
smaller builds and faster builds the
second was modernization and then
finally probably one of the most
important well I mean all of these are
really important and not mutually
exclusive
which is developer experience and if I
talk about smaller and faster builds and
we try and break it down you can kind of
categorize it here so like to have a
smaller build you're going to need to do
more analysis on the code and you're
gonna have to process more of the module
graph and then for faster builds though
you're gonna have to do less work and
reuse existing work that's already been
done so these are kind of conflicting
but for faster builds we completely
reacted the way that we define what a
chunk is and a chunk is just the
in-memory version of the bundle you see
created but we also added additional
features like uglify j/s we're gonna be
using it in parallel and cashing it out
of the box and we also modernized a lot
of the pieces that we had in just old
es5 object syntax and we moved to using
maps and sets but specifically I think
one of the most important is the
migration of our plug-in system we wrote
it completely from the graph from the
ground up and now we have what are
called hooks which are create
monomorphic code and we lazy compile
them and I want to actually take a
moment to explain well what is what is
this
mean who here is familiar with mano
morphism or polymorphism okay so this
may look familiar
so this is an example of one of the
methods that is available in our plug-in
system prior to rewriting it and so if
you see here this this method is what
certain classes in web pack will call
and plugins are listening to this event
and what's passed in is a arbitrary like
event string it's like an event emitter
if you've ever used it before but the
problem here is that this is polymorphic
it can be any amount of arguments and
there's no way for the JavaScript engine
stopped mices so you know our initial
answer was like oh why don't we get
clever and just make separate methods
with single arguments for each of them
well that was not going to work one
because we could have a plug-in system
that's ginormous you have infinite
amount of different event names and
argument types that can be passed in and
so it's unmaintainable and not really a
great contributor experience and so it's
like how could we how could we solve
this where we're creating monomorphic
functions but they're unique and you
know we don't have a billion of them
that we have to maintain so we use the
technique to lazily compile based on
what is listening to these events and I
know I'm going a little deep here but it
might make more sense in a moment but
you can see at the bottom we're
literally just composing a bunch of
strings that are JavaScript that compile
to these hooks and then we evaluate it
and so like a really great resource if
you're interested in this and I'll try
not to butcher the name but V dot J's
luff I got off wrote a great explainer
article that you can go to and take a
look at it to understand how this
accomplishes monomorphic code and if
you're on Twitter a lot like myself you
may have seen this article that was like
hey you may not need you know rust and
webassembly to speed up your JavaScript
well it turns out
like how that looks pretty familiar the
code that he showcased and look he's
doing the same thing so the point is
that we can create this monomorphic code
but we're doing it kind of evaluative ly
or lazy compiling it but please do not
do this in your normal projects this is
you know there are some parts of webpack
that execute 19 million times on large
code bases and so everything is in the
hot path for us and so just as Benedict
Moyer says or v8 senpai don't please
don't do this
please don't but so like what did this
represent to us and so on most web pack
builds we saw it get 98 percent faster
so 98% of the build time was reduced
just by people upgrading to web pack 498
yeah and you'd be like Shawn you're
lying stop you embellish all the time
and I'm like well it turns out that we
have people who are reporting 6 hours of
their build times on web pack 3 actually
who's 9 hours but this he stopped at 6
on this run and so we were like we have
an idea and after after showcasing this
in the in the web pack for alpha we
found 17 minutes 17 minutes from 9 hours
so like there's the URL you can go to it
I'm not lying and just to make sure so
that people would be like Shawn you're
still lying
we just before once we got into our
release candidacy I decided to you know
play a little game to see hey 1 could we
get people to upgrade to the beta so
that we could catch early bugs warning
signs things like that but - is this
like speed boost really is this for real
so um yeah I shot this out and like we
seeing 75% on some cases we were seeing
90% 80% and so it's the real deal and so
you know that build speed you know to
sum it up we were able to accomplish
that first piece in what our goals were
but then we still had smaller builds now
we have to do something basically
completely opposite to what trying to
get a faster build will do for you so
the first thing that we tried to
implement and we were able to do so is
JSON tree-shaking so if you ever use
JSON with webpack you'll notice that in
version 3 it would bundle all of the
pieces that you would import into it but
we found out that really like JSON is
just as a a stricter set of what
JavaScript is and so we could treat it
like an atmosphere module and only the
pieces that are now used will actually
get will stay in your code and so in
this case you know you can just see
we're just pulling in and importing one
property and that's all that actually
compiles when we minify the code we also
have a feature well I'll explain the
problem first so according to Equus grip
module specification or the harmony
module spec when you have multiple
exports inside of a file every single
one of them has to be evaluated and
executed to ensure that they are not
creating side-effects against each other
so what does that mean well if lodash is
exporting from a file essentially a
thousand exports each one of them has to
be included into your bundle so what we
did and you can see that here in this
tiny example so we did as we created
this trick we had to tell the compiler
some way like hey there are no side
effects here you can go ahead and ignore
those properties
and so that's what we did we created the
side effects property which now we're
asking library authors to include in
their package [ __ ] Jason's because what
webpack will do in production mode is it
will look for the presence of this this
property and it will simply prune it out
and in fact it actually makes builds
faster when we are in the beta stages we
found that our production builds were
faster than the develop memo builds
because of this feature because what
you're doing is you're ignoring tracing
those parts of the graph because you
know they aren't actually used so in
this case we saw something like in
webpack 3 you know 200 KB of minimize
code actually turned to 1 KB so hmm
really
all you need to do if you you know it's
so easy all I have to do is just tree
shake mangle your exports go POIs
minimize and then package authors have
to set side-effects oh that's ridiculous
you shouldn't have to do any of that and
that kind of gets into what developer
experience is about all you should have
to do is freakin run web pack and so out
of the box now in web pack four we
default to a production mode so all of
those things you saw in that bullet
point they just happen and so developer
experience to us meant we need to lower
the barrier to entry to people who are
trying these tools for the first time
not everybody understands the rigorous
and obnoxious history of JavaScript
modules and where they started and where
they are now and we also need to have
better defaults and thanks to libraries
like parcel we can now coin something
like zero config j/s and us zero config
doesn't mean you know like letting you
do whatever you want and shoving it into
one package and then hoping not the
feature that you don't use breaks and
causes a major breaking change it means
being able to actually extend a base
scenario to your users so that it can
you I oh you know bring your own zero
config j/s and so this is really the
line that we wanted to to cross so you
know by defaults you don't even need a
web pack config to use web pack for
every property has been defaulted and
what the future yeah now I'm not so that
what I'm trying to say though is that
not everybody will end up you know just
ripping out their web pack config
because the power of web pack is is
deeply rooted in how extensible we are
and so instead why don't we extend this
idea so we also created this feature
called mode and so mode is a property on
the config or a flag that you can pass
in the CLI and we default to production
like I said and you know what it
represents is that for development
you're going to want to have tooling for
the browser you're going to want to have
really fast incremental compilation and
you're gonna have better error messages
that you know don't take up an entire
console and then for production we're
optimizing for size we're optimizing for
the right kind of source code and we're
optimizing for file paths that are
understandable but don't leak you know
information to the people using your
website but it also means getting rid of
things that used to really cause us
problems like the Commons chunk plugin
and web pack for it's gone we've
replaced it with an API that does much
of this out of the box by default but on
top of that we have properties that give
you more control than Commons chunk did
and then finally you know build speed
was something that we took so seriously
that we wanted to be able to profile and
analyze really deeply any long-running
build and so we worked with Sam saucony
from Google who helped us implement a
special profiler that allows you to see
every plug-in and how long
takes right inside of the dev tools
timeline viewer online yeah so now you
can literally see and I mean this this
information may be more valuable to us
but it allows us to just say hey pop in
a plugin and send us the events JSON
file and it it's really useful for those
who are creating plugins themselves and
trying to analyze interactions and that
kind of leaves us to you know the
modernization in the Ryoka tech chure so
you know one of the most important
things that kind of held us back in web
pack three is that we treat everything
as a JavaScript module but we also were
championed with being able to implement
web assembly as a first-class citizen
and so this gave us the opportunity to
remove all of these everything is j/s
hacks or it allowed us to actually
implement wasm as a module type which
allowed us to also implement JSON as a
module type and it gave us JSON
tree-shaking and then what we're working
on right now is HTML and CSS module
types so we had to take and remove all
from you know our module factories is
what we call them all of the code
generation system that was specific to
JavaScript and we've you know isolated
it and so now with our web assembly is a
first-class module type you have code
like this this is um a newer library
called Walt who has heard of Walt it's a
subset of I guess you could say
typescript and it allows you to write a
very JavaScript like syntax as you see
up at the top and then all you have to
do is import it just like it's a
JavaScript module into your code and you
have used web assembly without doing
anything else at your fingertips this is
probably one of the most exciting things
to me is that you want to use a frame or
you want to use these things now what
these these library authors can do
is instantly compiled a web assembly
module and if it's available in the
package web pack will consume that
instead of the JavaScript and so you get
the 10x speed up instantly at your
fingertips and so the other pieces were
dropping node four so node four is no
longer supported for web pack and node
six is our minimum version but this
allowed us to convert the rest of the
codebase to using es6 features it a lot
of code to be more readable easier to
change using syntax that people
understand and contributors want to
actually leverage and now you know by
using these this new code v8 actually
has a great test bench for optimizing
paths that aren't as hot yet that should
be and I mean like as it was said
there's we're just scratching the
surface on all the different changes
that we've made and so you know smaller
builds and faster builds modernization
developer experience that is where
everything was routed in and so you
might be like alright Sean this is great
like how do i migrate so right now we
have the pr pending for our migration
guide and i'll talk about a little bit
more and then what about four frameworks
and plugins we've been working you know
ever since we released our alpha behind
the scenes with create react app pre-act
CLI the angular CLI view CLI teams to
make sure that and we we put extra focus
on them to ensure that they had a steady
path and there weren't blockers for them
to test early but for right now you know
in until we get that that migration
guide merged i'd say jump on our medium
publication or submit an issue and ask
how you can help and like I said the
angular CLI
is actually going to be now supporting
it in their next major release which I
believe is like next week so look to
have that automatically out-of-the-box
for you and then you know a shameless
plug to me you can always jump on my
twitch livestream which I do two times a
week and you can ask me questions any
time we work with people just to help
them migrate we also get people to
contribute to the codebase and you know
submit their first PR ever and even more
so we wanted to make sure that this
worked at scale and so Ken Shaw who's
surprised appearing in these slides you
know he is one of the lead engineers for
the Outlook Web App team well as of I
think a few days ago or was it yesterday
the Outlook Web App is now using webpack
for not only did the size of their
builds instantly shrink without making
any changes but their build times their
inner dev loop jumped from a hundred
seconds to 20 seconds and on a hundred
fifty person team we're talking millions
of dollars of Deb's time saved and so
we're hoping to accomplish that not just
for you know Microsoft and the outlook
team but by vetting it in dogfooding it
in that way we can ensure that it's a
great experience for you so what's next
like what's beyond web pack four so the
things that we're gonna focus on are
finishing the CSS is a module type HTML
is a module type URL and file as a
module type but as you can see what this
means is you don't have to use extract
text plug-in anymore you might not even
need he I know you might not even need
to have a CSS URL file loader we might
just have this supported out-of-the-box
as a module you'll be able to say hello
to CSS code splitting something that
doesn't exist today and actually you
know cause this kind of a pain point for
you know browser and load times but you
could also have HTML as an entry point
and then the other big feature that I'm
really excited about which is called web
packing lazon part two so you know when
we introduce what web assembly is a
first-class citizen we kind of can you
know the module type is called web
assembly / experimental and so the first
thing is to stay
lies it but then we're going to go ahead
and add a bunch of the features that we
that we already have on JavaScript and
apply it to web assembly and so this
means tree-shaking you can do that
dead code elimination scope hosting wise
modules and so this is super exciting
because now web assembly goes from being
something that you can use once or twice
to using it just like any other
JavaScript module and not taking a
perfect or a size hit or a runtime hit
and then maybe something that's really
special for me is it's presets so like I
said you know bring your own zero config
j/s these are just examples that I
played around with in a prototype but
what if it would be just this easy to
say at web pack can use Babel if exists
you can install that package and it just
reads your babel RC and throws in babel
loader what if as a package author you
have these composable parts that you can
share and leverage this looks very
similar to babel if you understand their
package structure and we're you know at
least i took the inspiration in this
prototype to kind of leverage it but can
use typescript really could just be can
it resolve type scripting can it load it
using a loader but the point is that
this is how you can extend 0 config so
with a couple packages that you would
add you still don't need a web pack
config yep thank you and so what's
beyond what's beyond for point X so
those are they're kind of like the
things that we can do right now without
causing a breaking change but what
what's beyond that so one of the most
important things that is lacking for web
pack is that we don't have a fully
persistent cache and so that's that's
the first one that we're gonna be
working on and so we actually kind of
worked really closely with the author of
hard source web pack plug-in new who has
probably the most experience with our
code base and you know disk caching and
so he wrote up a specification and you
can take a look at it on github
think it's under the the webpack five
tag but also things like multi-threading
our builds actually when we saw the
presentation or when I saw the
presentation yesterday about having
workers be native that was really
exciting especially to us who wants to
be able to have something right out of
the box from node but also have all of
our experimental module types become
stable and then what if we could bring
your own module type what if you could
write a module type that makes you not
even need a type script loader what if
you could take those types and treat it
as metadata and allow it to do static
you know program flow analysis and make
your code even smaller I see a future
where it's you want to use typescript
with web pack because it creates smaller
bundles and so I really have a you know
see a promise for bring your own module
type I mean I mean to be honest these
things are just a reflection of what you
asked for and so did you know that every
single one of you if you have a github
account can go to web packages or
forward slash vote and everyday even not
as a contributor or sponsor you get one
piece of influence every day that you
can vote on a specific feature so I mean
literally we put the power in you all
because that's who we represent you saw
our sponsors and backers we're a
grassroots project that represents
exactly what it means to have web
performance and developer experience
without making a sacrifice to each and
you know finally you know we shipped web
pack for what do we take away from it
one of the things that we announced when
we released the release candidate was
that you know we we said here's 30 days
log plugin and loader authors you get 30
days to upgrade we're not going to break
any changes between our RCE and final
and that was great for our team who owns
a lot of the core plugins and loaders
but it was a lot harder for people who
you know third-party plugins and so I
think what we're gonna do is focus more
on providing a migration guide for
loaders and
plugins and even just general updating
versus having a time window and I mean
overall like you know like I just said I
rambled about it a little early but we
are like what we do is exactly what you
asked us to and so we see this year of
JavaScript as being you know no more
talk of this fatigue but instead it's
having this mindset of embracing the
changes of our technology that are so
beautiful in JavaScript
some joke that we see a new framework
every two weeks but that's the most
beautiful part of our language in what
other language do you get to use syntax
that doesn't exist yet without a VM for
you Java people does that doesn't count
there is no other language it's it's a
JavaScript Renaissance and so we embrace
this we call it even a growth mindset at
Microsoft and so we ask you to do the
same and and help web pack just not be
yet another build tool so thank you guys
very much
oh yeah and try web back today
[Applause]